but I knew oh okay let me see okay so I
knew of your reputation because your
reputation you're a guy who whose
reputation precedes him I think okay I
think you are what is the reputation you
know I mean the madtv probably is is
like what I was like okay Bobby Lee yeah
yeah and I'm good friends with John
Barinholtz he's I would consider him my
best friend I love him and I look up to
his brother Mike and he's always been
really nice to me yeah and so I threw
Ike I think and all that it's like oh
yeah Bobby Lee Bobby Lee he's crazy you
know Bobby Lee will take his pants off
run around edit it up and so I'm being
honest and so before I met you I was
like okay I'm gonna meet Bobby Lee you
know he's gonna we're gonna I'm like
okay he's probably knowing or something
like then I met you and it was I totally
changed my perception right totally the
perception of me is that I'm annoying
not annoying but you know crazy crazy
yeah yeah you know but you are so funny
you're so funny oh thank you you are but
people have said that to me before
I'll show up at a club and they'll go
and then I've never worked for the club
before and they go wow we should had you
earlier I go why because I don't know we
just didn't book you because we heard
things inappropriate or annoying no not
annoying but just kind of crazy and you
know I mean eccentric in a weird way you
know my type of people don't know I'm
I'm not I'm not those things no you're
not no I I'm professional I show up I
know my lines
my audition mm-hmm I humble myself
sometimes I bomb I show up through my
stage time and I'm respectful and yeah I
I have done things when I first kind of
matter did some things for the first
three or four years I'm not proud of
well I stuck things in my butthole
because [ __ ] in the office people's
office but I'm guessing when you were
younger we have a term and in the
Phillipines become KS be like cooling
sup on scene when you were younger you
were probably that you were probably so
KSP where you always wanted the
attention so you inadvertently became so
annoying to other people even though
it was funny or perhaps you were naked
but I think you've matured since and I
think that people really now you're just
funny your job yes and now you strike me
as a guy who you've been through all the
[ __ ] and now you and you've come out of
it alive yeah and now you're just
[ __ ] great oh no I didn't know you
back then yeah I know but I know how I
was back then I've been sober now for
two years but I used to be wait the
[ __ ] to you yeah but I used to be that
whatever you called me the [ __ ] King
rest is so much stuff yeah
[Music]